Continental Tire Coach's Corner the
Georgetown head coach Patrick Ewing as
he picks up the first win of his career
beating Jacksonville yesterday
coach how does it feel hey coach that
was a big introduction thought it was
gonna be great thought it was gonna be
Dan unbelievable and awesome thanks for
thinking of me
Brett C's Patrick there he is there
there was an issue with the phone on his
end but he hears us now coach
congratulations when you wake up
yesterday how nervous are you coach in
your first game yeah I was very nervous
I was very nervous you know you know as
a player I think you know I was talking
to Jeff Van Gundy I said you know as a
player I was never nervous but as a
coach and you know people always said
when you go from an assistant coach to a
head coach it's a totally different
thing you wake up in the middle of the
night thinking about plays thinking
about you know what you need to do all
that things so I you know I was I was
very nervous but then once the game
started you know all the nervous the
nervousness went away
alright did you almost screw up and get
out of the coach's box like I did you
get warned that you were venturing too
far out of the coach's box yes I did but
you know you can't see it you can't see
it you know it blends in with the floor
so they put a towel over there and told
me you know this is this this is right
here if you see the towel then you know
you're out of the box no okay I wondered
what the towel was for I thought
somebody better picked that up
somebody's gonna slip on it so that was
just you saying hey I can't go past this
or I'm gonna get teed up well the rest
what it did say this is you know we're
putting this there we don't want to see
you up so if you get
this towel then make sure that you know
that you know you go if you get past
this you're gonna get teed up okay what
is your style to play we know how you
played it in college we know how you
played in the pros but what are you
teaching your kids this style you know
it's a little bit everything you know we
want to we want to we want to run but
you can't run if you do if you don't
have a guy that that's willing to run so
I'm trying to get them in shape to make
sure that they can get the ball up the
floor and push it you know it's force
layups and all that stuff and want to be
able to shoot the ball we put up a lot
of we put up a lot of threes yesterday
we I'm not I'm not sure I can't remember
how many how many of them we made but we
won that we want to have try to have a
touch all the bases three-point shots
post up layup free throws we want to be
able to do all of that so you know it's
my it's my vision that you know once you
know I get it all up and running that
we're gonna have the guys in there
that's gonna be able to do all those
things what are the realistic
expectations this first year you know
what I don't really have any
expectations this year all I want to do
is lay the foundation until I get all
the guys in that I want to get in you
know we have three great recruits coming
in next year and you know we'll see what
happens at the end of the year you know
we have we are working that we're
working the guys hard that continue to
work intended to develop we have you
know Jessica van is you know I keep on
telling them you're our best player if
you don't dominate it you don't have you
know great year this year it's on you if
you you know if you don't dominate we're
not gonna be do well both you and Marcus
Derrick's nard our two best players and
then our freshman's they have to develop
and continue grow every day he's a
Patrick Ewing brought to you by
Continental Tire Coach's Corner dear
kids know who you were when you played
well things oh you know they see my
jersey up on the wall
hiya paranoia they know about all of
that the intimidation the way you guys
took over college basketball well I mean
even if they didn't know what once I got
the job everybody seemed to have brought
that up so I'm sure they know about it
by now you had some special guests
yesterday were there any surprise guests
yesterday no surprise guess everyone
that was coming I knew I knew were
coming including Jordan yeah I know he
was coming you know he and I we spoke he
and I was supposed to go to dinner that
night and I told him you know what Mike
I have to concentrate on the game I'm
gonna take a pass on it so he and I
would get together at a later date
everybody that was covered I knew that
was coming Jeff Scott Scott Brooks you
know MJ Alonzo dikembe Allen was
supposed to come but he had some some
issues and he wasn't able to make it
it's pretty close everyone pretty cool
oh yeah everyone everyone came in and
you know show their support and I was
very I was very honored the the picture
in the locker room all the kids around
Jordan yeah that was your you're in the
background I'm looking for you there
they all the kids are like hey coach
Congrats a Michael Jordan's in the
locker room here well you know I wanted
I wanted to make sure that they you know
they we always talk about him everybody
wants to be great you know one of the
things I try to to talk to them about
everybody wants to be great but a lot of
people don't know you know what it takes
to be great they don't want to put in
the work to be great and he was one of
the people that even know how great he
was he's still put in the work
you know he's one of the people that I
talk about you know talk about all the
great players that they all want to
emulate but they all don't want to they
don't know what it takes to beat those
guys they all put in work the Didache
that the dedication the hard work
getting up in the middle you know early
in the morning going to one or getting
in a gym so all those things you know
they paid the price and a lot of these
young kids they all talk about they want
to be great but they don't don't they
never want to put in the work to be
great if I would have told you when you
were 18 that you were gonna be coaching
Georgetown one day what would you
thought when I was 18 I wasn't even
thinking about coaching sorry I'm
thinking about that you could you could
do this whether it's the NBA or college
I never thought out even when I was
playing I never even thought about
coaching I what what led me to coaching
was the guy in that photo that you were
just talking about you know when I
decided to retire he and I went was that
lunch or dinner I don't care what it was
but he and I was at dinner or lunch and
we were talking I was telling you know
telling him that you know I decided that
you know I'm gonna retire at the end of
that that that season and he was running
the wizards at the time and he said you
know why don't you come and yeah you
know work with me I'm gonna create a
position for you we try the coaching if
that doesn't work moving to the front
office he tried the front office
position and what 15 16 years later I'm
still doing it it's pretty cool we we
got an old Georgetown warm up jersey
warm up on eBay and so we in tried it we
tried to recreate the high paranoia we
didn't do a very good job with it but we
did send that video to you just we
thought that that might ease the you
know the nerves with you looking at us
trying to create a high paranoia well I
appreciate that but also your fire you
following me on Twitter Paulie is my
producer is
oh that's good I'm glad to hear that
yeah and then we're gonna we're gonna
either to go there or we're gonna see
you in New York you know so we're good
invited just let me know what I
definitely have tickets for you now I
was thinking maybe I could shoot some
lamp maybe I could get the layup line is
that asking too much it's a little bit
you know I know after the game I let you
come out and shoot some free throws but
in the layup line I might be one of the
better shooters on your team now coach
you might be it was fun to watch
yesterday and good luck Wednesday
against mount st. Mary's thing that I
really did it alright that's Patrick you
Patrick Ewing pretty good Continental
Tire coaches corner from Sunday rain to
snow and everything in between
Continental Tire is engineered attire
for what you do extraordinary
performance and reliability putting
confidence into driving for more info
and a location of a dealer near you
visit Continental Tire calm cutting home
tire for what you do for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]